[Music]
you're seeing a replica of the apollo
capsule because bitcoin literally went
to the moon since we did our first film
bitcoin the end of money as we know it
that was in 2014-15 and our film also
went ballistic it was pirated on
bittorrent on youtube and of course also
legally licensed on many tv channels
since then we also did another film
called cryptopia bitcoin blockchains and
the future of the internet about the
whole industry that was evolving slowly
in 2018-19
many have requested an updated and
upgraded version of the end of money
that's why we're here let's jump right
in and i'll be right back
[Music]
look closely
what do we all have in common
no matter what corner of the world you
live in
you need food
water
shelter
and money
half of every transaction involves money
in exchange for goods or services
stocks a loaf of bread illegal drugs
you gotta pay for it
we spend much of our lives chasing money
to make a living and accomplish our
dreams
but it's also an instrument of
destruction some might say evil driving
criminals to lie steel and even murder
the existing banking system extracts
enormous value from society and it is
parasitic in nature
money is a catalyst for the worst and
the best of human endeavor
before civilization
we created currency
fuel for wars
path to power
champion and enemy of innovation
money is so integral to our society and
our global economy that its true nature
remains a mystery to most
this is the story of money perhaps the
end of money as we know it
no matter how fat your bank account or
how thin your wallet to us it's all cold
hard cash there are some who want to
kill it
get rid of it
burn your dollars your euros your yen
and transform every penny you have into
ones and zeroes digital currency entrust
it to the web and computers spread
across the planet
magic internet money
is called cryptocurrency
bitcoin
invented in secret it was a gift to the
world it's not just the currency but
it's actually programmable money a
potential curse on bankers and there's
nothing that the the big banks or
politicians can do to stop it breaking
every government's grip on money supply
what the internet did for information
bitcoin is doing for money
could it be the new gold
no you have to really stretch your
imagination to infer what the intrinsic
value of bitcoin is
regulators the federal reserve the
banking system at least understand this
is a thing that they have to take
seriously
this is going to change the economic
culture bitcoin could be a micro
economic miracle worker and it could be
a macro economic wrecking ball
is bitcoin the currency of the future
a godsend for criminals
or a recipe for financial disaster
if you trust your money just as it is
we have a little story to share
this documentary was originally voiced
by john barrett of the bitcoins and
gravy podcast so when you see me or hear
me i'm updating the script giving you
better context or fixing stuff that we
got wrong okay on with the show
once upon a time there was a big party
with everyone standing around the punch
bowl drunk
politicians credited the strong economy
to their wise decisions businesses
jumped into new profitable markets
ignoring risk in fact the experts said
there was no risk
[Applause]
then troubling market data from minor
countries spooked the markets rumors
spread more bad news rattled housing
prices at the heart of the financial
world a major bank went insolvent
investors and businesses made a run on
the other banks demanding their cash
deposits the largest financial
institutions in the center of the modern
world were frozen
assets were seized
banks foreclosed a credit crunch
threatened the entire world economy
[Music]
and then
finally the government stepped in
the largest bank bailout ever
swift action by the head of state had
saved the day
remember that
no you don't
it happened 2 000 years ago
rome 33 a.d ground zero for the first
recorded liquidity crisis and government
bailout in history
the largest empire the world had ever
seen was brought to its knees by a
banking disaster
emperor tiberius used money from the
national treasury to bail out the
country's troubled banks and companies
history may not repeat itself but it
certainly rhymes
badly
[Music]
people in power and their money have
always been at the very center of it
the story of money is as old as
civilization itself
when we lived in small tribes keeping
track of debt was easy
you owed somebody a load of firewood a
neighbor owed you a piece of meat
credits and debits were kept in your
head a mental ledger
currency is a language that allows us to
express transactional value between
people
it's technology that's older than
the wheel it's as old as fire
when humans wanted to trade outside
their tribe or village they needed
something everyone could agree had value
something scalable
enter commodity monies
there were many kinds but each had to
embody the same five characteristics a
commodity money is relatively scarce
easily recognizable can be cut into
smaller pieces you can substitute one
piece for another of equal value
and you can carry it around without too
much trouble
in ancient rome it was salt
the aztecs used cacao beans it was whale
teeth on fiji
yak dung in tibet
shells in africa and china
grains metal ivory rare stones leather
fish
if it had the five characteristics of
commodity money someone probably used it
as currency
and then you ask what value do these
currencies have
if you go into a primary school you'll
see children exchanging rubber bands and
tamagotchi and pokemon cards and
baseball cards and sweets and candy and
any other form of currency people invent
currency when they have no other
currency and now they're going to invent
digital currencies
but commodities that aren't durable are
a lousy store of value
a bad cacao crop or a huge new salt
discovery can throw your currency and
economy into turmoil a more stable
system was needed
about 2500 years ago the first metal
coins were minted in china
and in what is now turkey
these coins shared the same five
characteristics with commodity money but
were also very durable
in some cases coins are the only thing
left of entire civilizations
money does not originate with
governments
money arises naturally as markets begin
to develop and as people with a division
of labor realized that if i have eggs
and you have a cow we may need some
medium of exchange in order for you to
buy my eggs for me to buy your cow
coins were an objective and universal
unit of account and they allowed people
to buy and sell goods over vast regions
the market economy was born
coins worked
but only if people trusted that the king
or emperor who issued them wasn't
cheating on the metal content
using coins also meant that an authority
now controlled the supply of your
currency money and political power were
inextricably linked
centralized
yeah so i wish we made this point a
little bit clearer you see the main
issue here is once somebody is in
control of that money supply that
introduces the potential for corrupting
the system it doesn't matter whether
they wear a crown or a suit
minting coins in a steady and
predictable manner allowed economic
growth and stability
the wushu coin in china retained its
value for 500 years
in constantinople the solidus lasted for
700 years
but in those times the coins didn't have
the the milled
this sort of milled edge they were flat
and what used to happen was as coins
were passing from people to people
people would cut little bits off
and in fact
some of the taxation that the kings
would do would actually be take
1 8 of the coin off
taxes built castles and financed
military campaigns expensive hobbies
soon royal mints were substituting
cheaper metals for silver and gold this
is called debasement and europe's kings
made a habit of it
the currency of france was debased every
20 months
for 200 years
if no one can trust the gold or silver
content of your coins how can you trade
with other countries
[Music]
international merchants found a solution
they recognize that one person's debt
has value
it can be traded or transferred
when those ious came from reputable
sources they could be used as a form of
money
paper money this money was not based on
hard commodities or metal but instead on
someone's promise to pay
merchant families like the medici in
15th century florence acted as
clearinghouses for these ious
it worked like this
an english trader ordered a shipment of
italian cloth from the medici for 100
gold coins his promise to pay the medici
was put on paper meanwhile the medici
owed 100 gold coins to another trading
partner for delivery of wine from france
the parties didn't go to the expense of
transporting and exchanging gold coins
instead the paper was transferred
everyone agreed that the paper had value
100 gold coins but only because everyone
trusted the medici as solvent middlemen
they had created a paper money machine
within a few generations they rose from
low crime to high finance
their great wealth helped fuel the
italian renaissance and elevated the
family to levels of enormous political
power the power to marry into royal
families and get elected as popes
the ties binding money to power politics
and influence now ran through church and
state
[Music]
merchants had proven that creating paper
currency could be wildly profitable
goldsmiths wanted in on the action
imagine it like this if the gold smith
had seen over a period of time that some
of the coins he was storing for people
were gathering dust the people who owned
them
don't need them right now so what if i
go and lend them out into the community
and i charge some interest on this loan
so he starts out lending some of these
gold coins and then
later he realizes actually people don't
even want the gold coins they just want
the piece of paper that says the the
gold coins are in the bank and with the
goldsmith
so i can now make a loan
with
these pieces of paper
and whatever i write on a piece of paper
as long as people trust me
they'll trust the paper
and effectively the the goldsmiths and
the early day bankers
they had literally acquired the power to
print money
more and more private paper money from
merchants and banks circulated and began
to rival the crown's coins the power
inherent in controlling and issuing
money began slipping away from the
rulers
they couldn't tax or debase this new
kind of money but they had bigger
ambitions than ever with trading posts
colonies and empires that now stretched
across the globe
for centuries european countries would
take turns building massive fleets and
waging war on each other to rule the
world
[Applause]
government wanted to take the people's
money in order to finance its wars
that's essentially the history of money
money and warfare go together
war is expensive one year's income taxes
simply aren't enough kings and queens
had to borrow money against future taxes
they needed a ground-breaking financial
innovation government bonds
the loans came from rich merchant
families and goldsmiths who by now had
become powerful financiers and bankers
sovereign debt and deficit spending had
been born
[Music]
in 1694 the bank of england was
established to fund a war against france
england's central bank was privately
owned and granted the monopoly to issue
banknotes paper that could be redeemed
for an equal amount of gold from the
government coffers
the central bank soon also managed the
entire debt of the crown
money has been a tool of sovereignty for
centuries being able to issue currency
gave you the power but it also gave the
value to that monetary supply by backing
it with the force of state
with essentially the debt of state
[Music]
when the u.s won independence from
britain the first article of the new
constitution gave congress the exclusive
right to coin money
this currency's value was tied to gold
in government vaults from 1781 until the
panic of 1907 the financial system of
the us was an economic petri dish brief
central banks state banks private banks
private currency government currency
depressions strong growth recessions
regular boom and bust cycles
the long term as far as capital is
concerned people want predictability
people want stability
from the back of that they can plan now
it's very hard to plan in the long term
without such a level of volatility
in 1913 bankers and politicians decided
that it was in the country's best
interest and theirs to have a permanent
central bank
they created the federal reserve
among its jobs expand or contract the
supply of a single national currency the
federal reserve note
the dollar was tied to gold and
strategic control of it would avoid
booms that lead to busts
at least that was the plan
then came 1929
the great depression would have a
profound effect on monetary policy
worldwide
i shall ask the congress for the one
remaining instrument to meet the crisis
fraud
executive power
soon the fed had printed nearly all the
money it legally could to pump life back
into the economy it needed gold to fire
up the mint
so in 1933 president roosevelt issued a
controversial executive order
forcing all u.s citizens to sell their
gold to the federal reserve at a fixed
price
or go to prison
after world war ii america became the
global superpower and with it the us
dollar emerged as the most important
reserve currency in the world
[Music]
other countries pegged their currency to
the dollar which could still be redeemed
for gold
in fact the u.s owned more than half of
the world's gold reserves
[Music]
in the next few decades more dollars
flowed to foreign countries governments
began debasing their coins with cheaper
metals and printing more of their own
currency than they had in gold
the bond between precious metals and
paper currency
was cracking
this is a 1966 50 cent piece it was the
last coin uh in regular circulation in
australia to contain silver and it
contains 80 silver so in 1966
this was 50 cents nowadays it's eight
dollars roughly
in silver alone
by 1966 foreign nations had had enough
of the us collecting gold and printing
cash
and they had more value in dollars than
the u.s had bullion in its vaults
they demanded gold in return for their
paper dollars
arguments about the value of the dollar
versus their currency ensued
in 1971 president nixon settled the
matter he severed united states currency
from the gold standard
i have directed secretary connelly to
suspend temporarily the convertibility
of the dollar in the gold or other
reserve assets
except in amounts and conditions
determined to be in the interest of
monetary stability and in the best
interest of the united states
never again could anyone legally demand
u.s government gold in exchange for
paper dollars
for better or worse the dollar was now
backed solely by the full faith and
credit of the united states government
the wealthiest nation the world had ever
known would bet its future on a single
word
trust
1971 really was a watershed moment when
the world's reserve currency and with it
most of the world lost its tether to
gold that was a really big deal
people have this mythology of money that
is based on very little fact
and one of the nice things about bitcoin
is that it forces people to start to ask
questions about the fundamentals of
money
bitcoin is an attempt
to adopt the advanced computerized
system that we have
the internet to resurrecting what money
used to be all about
[Music]
i think our dollar policies our monetary
policies our fiscal policies have
absolutely created a nation of debtors
not just personal debt not just
corporate debt but government debt and
you have to look at those all together
as one big thing what is the wealth of
the nation well the wealth of the nation
is a gigantic hole of money that we owe
to the rest of the world that is never
going to be paid back
today the united states pays more than
400 billion dollars in interest to its
creditors every year
hold on hold on
sorry for directing again john that was
back in 2015 when the total debt of the
united states government was around 18
trillion dollars
today it's more like 29 trillion dollars
and growing by the day
let's just hope interest rates stay low
[Music]
when a government spends more money than
it collects in taxes
it simply borrows more or it creates
more
at one time every piece of paper money
was backed by gold
remember for every twenty dollar bill
there was twenty dollars worth of gold
in the government vault
not anymore
[Music]
today governments create currency by
first creating bonds or treasury bills
these bonds are sold in the market
generating funds for the government that
issued them
large banks buy us bonds to flip them
selling them to the federal reserve at a
profit this is the magic money machine
you see the fed is america's central
bank but it doesn't have any money
no cash on its balance sheets
when a bank buys a bond and takes it to
the federal reserve the fed simply says
thank you mr banker here's the principle
and some profit new money isn't
exchanged it simply appears on the
bank's accounts magic
[Music]
the fed also sets the bar for how much
interest you pay for a car home or
business loan
the federal reserve has been given the
impossible task of trying to run the
credit and monetary system as though we
are the soviet union
it's the central planner for the for the
key aspect of capitalism which is how
money and credit is allocated
the federal reserve on balance uh does
not help the economy on balance it hurts
the economy and it's bound to make
mistakes even with the best of
intentions
the fed is also supposed to boost
employment with low interest rates
encouraging people and businesses to buy
more goods and services
governments getting involved in money
is a good thing and it's also a bad
thing it's a good thing because
money
is the arteries of the economy the blood
supply of the economy markets are
subject to
bouts of euphoria and despair
and it makes sense for governments to
back currency and manipulate it moving
the money supply up and down is the most
powerful way to
sedate that
boom and bust cycle
manipulating the supply of money has
short-term and long-term consequences
[Music]
central banks aim to create new money
carefully strategically and very very
slowly
releasing more money into the economy
causes prices to rise ideally by two
percent every year that's supposed to
foster economic growth
but two percent inflation means the
buying power of one cash dollar in your
pocket today will be 98 cents next year
and less nearly every year to
come so what does that mean
if you earned a dollar in 1913 you could
buy 16 loaves of bread
today a dollar barely buys you one
okay time for another update
the official statistics say it's about a
dollar fifty these days
but that depends on where you live where
you shop and which numbers you trust
that's not a quaint notion of how cheap
things used to be
it's proof that the value of your cash
is slowly withering away
that one dollar invested at two percent
in 1913 would now be worth
dollars and 24 cents more than 600
percent return versus a near total loss
the us dollar has gone from being worth
one dollar to now being worth about four
cents
so that's you know 96 of its original
value and it's a direct result of
government control
well these numbers would look way worse
now with all these new trillions
floating in the system
you see the officials will deny that
inflation is happening and then maybe
they will fudge the numbers then they
will say it's just temporary but
ultimately what it means is that the
money in your bank account is worth a
little bit less every single day
and the thing is we haven't even gotten
to the crazy part of our financial
system
governments don't create money from thin
air all alone
you play a key role in the magic money
machine
it's not really the central banks that
are the problem and they're part of the
problem but the real problem is that
we've given the power to create money
to the same banks that caused the
financial crisis
we put our paychecks and savings into a
bank account and draw from it as we need
it the banks are custodians of our money
right
wrong
it is now the property of the bank on
their balance sheets they can do just
about anything they want with it for
example create new money
here's how
your bank account shows 100
but the bank only holds three and loans
97 to bob to buy something
in the bank's computers you still have
100 in your account but bob now has 97
dollars of new virtual money in his
account just digits on a computer screen
there's no cash no gold or anything else
backing up the new numbers in bob's
account
just his promise to pay it back
this is new money created as debt
when those 97 are spent say in a shop
the shop owner deposits into another
bank and it is let out again and again
and again and each of these people have
numbers in their accounts showing that
they own this money
so your original one hundred dollars has
multiplied now there are over three
thousand three hundred dollars in the
system
this process of loaning out far more
money than a bank actually has as cash
on hand is called fractional reserve
banking
in the uk 97
of the money that exists
is just numbers in the computer system
and those numbers are created by the
banks
banks earn untold billions in interest
every year by creating and lending
virtual money what's more banks don't
even need your deposit to create new
money if they consider someone credit
worthy for a loan they can put new magic
money into his or her account and start
charging interest
so reporters talk about bitcoin as
though it's a as though it's the first
digital currency
but actually we use digital currency
every time you make a transaction
through internet banking or through your
your bank card
actually it's not even just digital
currency it's digital currency that is
created by the banks essentially i have
nothing
in other words all new money is debt
in paychecks bank accounts
401ks that loan to bob credit card debt
your home loan
all began life as virtual money created
by the banks
the entire system is based on trust
trust in the bank's solvency trust in
the debtor's ability to repay their debt
if all bank customers demanded just
three percent of their deposits right
now in cash
this run on the banks would reveal the
truth
almost none of that paper currency you
think is in your bank account exists
it never did
this seems pretty shaky but believe it
or not as long as there is trust in the
system it actually works
and without our trust well
[Music]
selling subprime loans and betting they
will fail may not be sacred
but it is lucrative
as much as one quarter of our best and
brightest are being lured by the siren
call of the money machine
instead of science engineering or
medicine they chose a career playing
with betting with other people's money
to get rich quick very rich
and sometimes they take shortcuts
[Music]
my ancestors in greece talked about the
corrupting influence of power
and nothing has changed in these three
thousand years when you give control
over massive amounts of money to a few
individuals they will take advantage of
that control
banks today are factoring in fines and
money laundering and all the rules that
they break into their cost of doing
business jp morgan is today coming out
and saying that bitcoin is uh not a
legitimate way of doing business banks
today are tied into a system that is
completely rigged to basically harvest
money from the entire global economy and
pump it into the hands of very few
don't get consumed
[Music]
the existing banking system is cozy it's
captured the regulators it extracts
enormous value from society without
delivering anything in return and it is
parasitic in nature
the banks play a very pivotal role in an
economy you look at any successful
economy it has successful banks there's
a very close correlation with banking
profits and the economy as a whole
in medieval europe a banker who couldn't
repay depositors was hanged
today that same banker would get bailed
out paid bonuses and enjoy some tax
benefits too
[Music]
[Music]
today's financial innovators package
assets in ever more complex ways slicing
dicing securitizing always using someone
else's money they sell debt transfer
risks leverage bets
that's what they call innovation
history teaches that the most
revolutionary and disruptive innovation
nearly always comes from the fringe not
from corporate cubicles
true innovators see the world
differently they see the big picture
creating new products and entire systems
that lead to new industries
steve jobs called them the square cogs
in round holes
unsurprising that new innovations always
come from a niche group of early
adopters because it is inherently very
hard for many people to realize the
benefits of new technologies
a radical new idea is often met with
skepticism ridicule even hostility from
those who stand to lose the most from
its success
case in point
the automobile
in the late 19th century carl benz and
others built the first cars contraptions
that could threaten the stagecoach and
railroad industries these self-propelled
vehicles or road trains would certainly
scare horses injure people and damage
roads cars the railroad barons said were
just too dangerous
and to protect us they used their power
to pass a law in 1865 it required every
automobile in england to observe a four
mile per hour speed limit and to be
operated by a crew of three a driver an
engineer and a flag man
this heroic flagmen walked in front of
the car to warn fellow citizens of the
coming danger
the railroad tycoons the lawmakers the
self-appointed gatekeepers used
regulation to stifle innovation
but they didn't invent the flagman he's
been around for a long time
for centuries very few could read books
were copied by hand the people in
control political and religious leaders
wanted to keep it that way and they
greeted johann gutenberg's printing
press with licensing laws publishing
bans
taxes
in some parts of the world printing was
a crime punishable by death after all
they were just protecting us from
dangerous ideas
before the printing press there were an
estimated 30 000 books in all of europe
50 years later there were 10 million
as gutenberg's invention flourished the
dark ages withered progress couldn't be
stopped
but the flag man never stops trying
his master set him loose on each of
these innovations because they
threatened someone's profits someone's
control
[Music]
but remember this is a story about money
what if a technological innovation
allowed anyone in the world to be their
own bank
to create a currency free from taxes and
banking fees
[Music]
the u.s constitution forbids citizens
from printing or minting their own
currency
competing with or undercutting reliance
on the u.s dollar
in 1998 bernard von notthouse decided to
test the resolve of the federal
government
the liberty dollar was available in gold
silver platinum and copper
it was available in three forms both in
specie in other words gold and silver
in paper as warehouse receipts and in
digital form
obviously the government didn't like it
they arrested me
and convicted me of counterfeiting fraud
and conspiracy and i'm currently
awaiting
22 years sentence in federal prison
[Music]
ultimately the feds didn't lock him up
and throw away the key north house got
away with six months home arrest and
probation
was at a hacker's convention in another
one there was a young
hacker there
who used the alias of satoshi nakamoto
and he talked to a friend of mine and he
identified the liberty dollar in me as
inspiring him to create a new currency
this is actually the only recorded
eyewitness account second hand of
someone meeting satoshi in person and
that was in 2005 quite extraordinary but
personally i'm not even sure i believe
it and i'm not really that interested
i'm much more interested why satoshi
created bitcoin anonymously
bernard von naughthouse's arrest for
creating private money may also have
inspired bitcoin's inventor to keep a
lower profile publishing the invention
under an alias
and vanishing
part of me is interested to know like
who satoshi is
maybe that's part of the mystique of the
story it's completely irrelevant to the
functioning of bitcoin because we have
the
the
code to read
but it would be kind of fun to know
who is
archimedes
who is
euclid
we don't know
we don't know if euclid was one person
or multiple people and you know what it
doesn't matter
euclidean geometry works whether i know
who euclid was or not whether euclid was
a moral and good person or whether he
was a corrupt plutocrat and a bastard
science and mathematics have
essential
truth that stands alone irrespective of
its inventors and irrespective of their
motives
well
bitcoin is
a system based on mathematical truths
and these mathematical truths stand
alone
we can read the source code in bitcoin
and understand it and it will be true
whether satoshi nakamoto is a man a
woman a collection of individuals a
government agency or aliens from the
future
you see it actually wouldn't have worked
any other way think about it
if a silicon valley funded startup or a
government or some professor would have
founded it it would have never worked
because remember who the early adopters
of bitcoin were cypherpunks
cryptoanarchists libertarians and yeah
drug dealers too so this antifragile
nature actually was built in from the
very start and remember this is also
helpful because a quasi-religious
movement is forming around bitcoin the
maximalist and that's really helpful if
you have an anonymous founder with some
mystique around it
bitcoin is an open source software
protocol like much of the code
supporting the internet and email
open source means anyone everyone can
use the protocol no one person or
company can control it every change to
the software is public open and
transparent
the code was first developed by satoshi
then there were dozens now hundreds of
programmers constantly collaborating to
improve bitcoin's features and security
so what makes bitcoin a breakthrough
it tackles an ancient human dilemma and
solves a computer science problem
any shared information or data can be
flawed corrupted
anything can be faked
how do we know that what we're receiving
can be trusted
in our traditional mindset it's very
important to know who is behind this
currency because their reputation is
significant in knowing that our funds
and the true wealth is actually safe
in finance we rely on trusted third
parties like banks credit card companies
remittance services they keep track of
money as it moves from one account to
another and they charge us handsomely
for it we trust that their digital
ledgers of credits and debits balance
a financial system that cuts out these
middlemen could be faster cheaper
and more secure
but bitcoin is digital music and movies
are easily pirated copied stolen how can
a digital currency retain value if
anyone can make a million copies
the answer is at the core of satoshi's
invention
a bitcoin is not a file on a computer
it's an entry in the publicly
distributed database called the
blockchain
just as the medici kept a ledger of
credits and debits
today's banks record each transaction as
a plus and minus in their ledgers now we
call them databases
bank accounts are replaced by a digital
wallet that you alone control
bitcoin's ledger is the blockchain a
record of every bitcoin in existence and
every bitcoin transaction ever made it
always balances because no bitcoin ever
leaves it
[Music]
when a bitcoin is sent from one digital
wallet to another what they are really
sending is control over that part of the
database
code that is a unique key for the new
owner as the network processes
transactions it constantly synchronizes
the one ledger across the global network
each computer or bitcoin miner has a
complete and identical copy
and because the blockchain is public it
cannot be controlled by any one person
or computer owners of the bitcoin mining
computers are rewarded with new bitcoins
for processing transactions and keeping
the network secure
[Music]
in other words the bitcoin network
replaces banks and bankers
today the combined computing power of
this global network is greater than the
500 biggest super computers combined
times 10 000.
hold on hold on hold on that fact always
fascinated me
10 000 times the top 500 super computers
put together that's crazy but today that
number would be closer to 5 million
unbelievable now critics have always
said
there's one thing that worries them
about bitcoin it is controlled by china
because most of the computing power is
in china well that used to be true but
recently china actually banned bitcoin
mining
what happened was that half of the
network power the hash power
dropped
but those miners put the hardware back
to other countries to the us to canada
to kazakhstan
as a result the bitcoin network is even
stronger even more globally distributed
than it was before
now why did china ban bitcoin obviously
it's a risk it's a threat to a fiat
currency we understand that now but the
other is the environmental debate
sure the bitcoin network consumes a lot
of energy a lot of it is fossil fuels so
the concern is correct but if you look a
little bit deeper into the statistics
and lazy journalists never do this
bitcoin miners move to wherever the
energy is cheapest and that is in most
countries of the world already
sustainable energy that's why bitcoin is
actually driving fossil fuels out and
increasing sustainable energy
it's almost concern trolling from the
media it's like we are very concerned
about the energy impact of bitcoin
ah you should really check out the
energy impact of capitalism or even
better the energy impact of war do you
know who the largest consumer of energy
in the united states is
the military right and the largest
consumer of oil also and the biggest
polluter in the world is the military
so
[Music]
pardon me if i
don't take that concern
so seriously
[Music]
central banks create money to boost the
economy and try to pull it back out
before inflation heats up but no one
knows how much magic money global banks
are creating to boost their profits with
questionable loans
bitcoin is completely the opposite it's
totally transparent you know exactly how
many exists
the computer code behind bitcoin has a
built-in brake pedal cutting the
creation of bitcoins in half every four
years
this ensures a transparent controlled
scarcity
and ultimately limits the total number
of bitcoins to 21 million
no lobbyist no politician no banker can
create more
or change the mathematical rules
dictating their creation
advancing accountability and that's
something i think is most exciting about
bitcoin and the technology behind it is
not so much that it will supplant the
dollar or that it will supplant
government itself
but that all of a sudden there's a
competitor to government and the
government itself now needs to look over
its shoulder more than it did
in 2014 the believers of bitcoin
thought and dreamed about replacing the
dollar but clearly that hasn't happened
and in my view it will never happen just
like the internet gave us tweets and
blogs and ebooks but it didn't replace
books or bookstores
remember a commodity money is relatively
scarce
easily recognizable can be cut into
smaller pieces you can substitute one
piece for another of equal value
and you can carry it around without too
much trouble
let's talk about these five
characteristics one more time to drive
the point home right so bitcoin clearly
is scarce in fact some would argue it's
the scarcest financial asset in the
world right the inflation rate the
bitcoin mining has slowed down so it
gets scarcer and scarcer every four
years it is divisible we can divide it
100 million times it's transportable i
can send it to anyone on the planet and
it doesn't matter which country you're
in the verifiability is interesting i
can verify my bitcoin immediately in a
split second but a fake dollar bill
a fake gold coin i'm not so sure i could
spot that
back to you john
this digital currency has the five key
characteristics of money but is it a
store of value
is it stable or will it diminish over
time like a commodity rendered useless
or a crop that fails
so this was really the big question of
the first
seven eight years of bitcoin
can it be a store of value bitcoin has
been the best performing financial asset
of the last decade no doubt about it but
it has been volatile let's be honest so
how i like to think about it is
short-term versus long-term volatility
right over the long run fiat currencies
lose value by inflation every couple of
years you lose you lose dudes we've seen
the statistics
bitcoin however
increases in value over the long run but
on the short term well it can lose 10
maybe even 50 over a short period of
time you have to be prepared for that
could not miss the point more
effectively than by thinking of bitcoin
as a currency and payment network that
will make shopping easier for the first
world
bitcoin is about everything else
everywhere else
there are 2.5 billion people without a
bank account
with bitcoin a mobile phone with an
internet connection is now a bank with
access to the global marketplace
what happens when bitcoin services and
infrastructure and bitcoin wallets and
payment processes start going into these
countries these people will be able to
gain benefits from trade where they
could not previously
these people will be able to
send money home
international remittance which is one of
the major pain points of the current
financial system
seven years later stefan has become a
major voice as a bitcoin only educator
and podcaster so good to see you after
so many years and so i'm just reflecting
back on what you said
told us in 2014-15
what's your quick take on that one
well i think to be honest i came out
pretty well from that right because i
was just basically saying it's going to
enable more and more people to transact
around the world where currently they're
not able to now could we have known back
then that
the message of day-to-day transactions
all happening on chain that didn't
really pan out that said
lightning network now has become
has grown and come to a level now where
it can be used for day-to-day communists
i probably could not have foreseen how
quickly nation-state adoption would have
happened obviously el salvador being the
big example there of
a country adopting bitcoin as legal
tender which is obviously a huge step
so we were thinking of building
bitcoin
city
this small central american country has
even announced a new form of government
bond it will hold half of the funds in
bitcoins and use the other half to build
infrastructure
they have also started to mine bitcoins
with clean geothermal energy from an
actual volcano people can potentially
invest into el salvador
and be funding the bitcoin city project
the interesting part is it has i believe
it's a 6.25 coupon
and on top of that there will be a
bitcoin dividend also
[Music]
we actually built this world that we
live in over the last two or three
hundred years we've made some mistakes
we've learned to make things better
the idea that there's some magic key
that if you just sort of stop doing a
few things that there'll be this perfect
order that will settle is a very
childish ideological delusion in my
opinion but that is not to say
that bitcoin isn't an exciting thing
it's a terrifically exciting thing
but we have to try and engage with it
with working minds not with magical
thinking
people are suggesting
that it's going to be another world
currency
rivaling the dollar or the euro or the
yen i think that's
not going to happen
i prefer to trust the banks or the
central government compared to the
bitcoin is because someone's accountable
whereas with the bitcoin it's completely
deregulated
there's no central control
there's no one held accountable
it is a free float it's purely demand
and supply driven
[Music]
williams so clearly this is
not a currency currencies don't behave
like this but what this is is a high
risk speculative commodity
so for the entrepreneurs the bankers the
governments and everyone else studying
and watching bitcoin all i have to say
is that there will probably be a lot of
volatility in an upward trajectory and
to buckle up
oh boy
so what's your first reaction to this oh
my god i feel like i look like a child
um it's been uh seven years i think
since i said that um we actually just
celebrated our tenth year anniversary so
for any company that's a really big
milestone in cryptocurrency world uh
that makes us the ogs and uh kind of an
original firm um so we have a lot of
things to celebrate
so not only have we survived and helped
build this economy up um but the things
i'm most proud of is that our users have
performed over a trillion dollars worth
of on-chain transactions we've had over
80 million people test and use
blockchain.com wallets on ios android
and web and really built out a robust
business
[Music]
we've also built out a full
institutional offering though so now we
do custody we do lending we have a
venture fund and we're also working with
protocol projects to do all kinds of new
exciting things like get distribution
into the retail base and much more so
we're starting to look a little bit more
ironically like a jp morgan in some ways
but with the intent of building out a
crypto services firm for the next 10
years and the digitization of financial
services has blended with crypto and um
now it is going to run rampant through
all these institutions um and without a
doubt not only are they going to start
offering crypto
you know services to all their clients
um but every single financial service
provider will have to have a crypto
offering or a crypto
service within the next decade
bitcoiners all over the world have
kick-started a cultural movement and the
most hardcore supporters are the
so-called maximalists on social media
you've probably seen their laser eyes
huddle and stacking sets memes
sets stands for satoshis or tiny
fractions of bitcoin
it's more about this idea of reflecting
and realizing that bitcoin is going to
be the money of the world
the general idea is you want to be
accumulating sats whether you're mining
the coins earning them or buying them
because we see this like we're playing
out this game of hyperboot colonization
and so in 10 or 15 years or we don't
know when the music the music is going
to stop and when the music stops you
want to be holding a chair i'm
fascinated by the whole bitcoin
maximalism like cultural movement
if you will so the origin of the term
bitcoin maximalist was actually an
epithet it was an insult a put down term
by vitalik essentially he was trying to
get interest drum up interest into his
altcoin for me
the real competition for bitcoin is not
against altcoins it's actually against
gold and the us dollar the biggest
financial mistake you can make right now
is to own an amount of bitcoin that you
cannot afford to lose because it's super
risky and you may lose it
the second biggest financial mistake you
can make is not to own any because
you put one percent of your net worth in
bitcoin most people can afford to lose
one percent of the net worth and if i am
right it's going to be more than 100 of
your net worth so with a non-material
exposure you change your life no what
you would spend with your on a romantic
weekend with your wife
say sorry we're not going to do that
this weekend i'm going to just buy
bitcoin consider it spend it disappear
check in seven years
i either gave you bad advice and cost
you a weekend or i want a grandkid
called juancito
[Laughter]
the digital age has fundamentally
changed the world we have embraced
digitized music
film medical records communications the
internet
the free exchange of information and
currency can fuel revolutions
help in a disaster
but our money is shackled to the 20th
century
manipulated by governments and banks
the champions of bitcoin ask us to
imagine payments without a middleman
investments without a broker loans
without a bank insurance without an
underwriter charity without a trustee
escrow without an agent betting without
a bookie record keeping without an
accountant global secure
nearly instant and free
is it fantasy or the future of money and
commerce
[Music]
we started this journey in the moon
capsule
will bitcoin continue to go to the moon
my personal theory is that no one will
compete against bitcoin as a store of
value i think we are seeing the
beginning of the end of fiat money we're
also seeing the birth of digital gold we
are seeing the rise of bitcoin that's my
prediction but you might disagree let's
see and speak in seven years
i love bitcoins i'm really into bitcoin
well satoshi nakamoto that's the name i
love to say and we don't know much about
him but he came to save the day
if you don't know what a bitcoin is
right usually the way people describe it
is uh digital cash it's money for the
internet
of bitcoin as you're going into the old
blockchain of bitcoin i know you're
going to rain gonna rain
he's like well i can tell you but
there's a fee
down the road it will be told about the
death of old mount gox about traders
trading alter coins and miners mining
now bitcoin is a new technology i like
to say it's banking likes
all
of the
[Music]
old
convenience
or bitcoin i know you're going to rain
gonna rain until everybody knows
everybody knows you know when i go
online and i buy like i don't know a
pair of socks if i pay with a credit
card
i'm just buying socks right if i buy
those socks with bitcoin
it's a revolution
[Music]
i am sticking it to the man
[Music]
oh
lord pass me some more
there's always people who are not ready
to get into the new technology you know
like when the internet came out there
was people going nah
i don't think this is gonna be popular
and then email came out and people like
nah
this isn't gonna catch on
and now bitcoin comes out people like i
don't think i'm like aren't you sick of
being wrong
get on this train you know
[Applause]